hey everybody it's my photos from water
flows calm and I want to give you a
heads up on a webinar that I'll be doing
on Thursday February 8th with investor
inspiration I'll be part of a panel of
six speakers I'll be speaking at 2:45
eastern time which is 145 Chicago time
and I'll be talking about my favorite
order flow trading method you know these
markets have been very crazy the last
few days and this might be a nice break
from the markets for you so all you have
to do is go to the link below in the
description of this video or go to my
website order flows comm slash register
dot HTML and it'll take you to the sign
up link and enter your best email and
what I'll be talking about is one
reading the order flow charts you know
most people find them very confusing
now most trading software's nowadays
have an order flow volume foot print
chart some people call it volume metrics
and for a lot of people that are new to
order flow trading it is a bit confusing
because honestly you don't know what
you're looking at so one of the things
I'll be touching on early on the
presentation is how to read the order
flow chart so it makes sense so you know
what you're looking at then the next
thing I'm talking about is using order
flow tools to support your trading
decisions right you know being a trader
is all about making decisions and
ideally making good decisions and I will
show you how you can use order flow to
help you in your decision making process
now I'm not saying you have to replace
your method of trading with order flow
rather imagine if you're already
successful if you have some measure of
success already in the markets but you
want to refine your entries refine your
exits maybe get a little bit more out of
a trade you know understanding the order
flow how to read it can give you those
little edges you know those little edges
over time add up to nice rewards and
we'll show you how to use order flow to
control your risk you know everyone
always says you know limit your risk
limit your risk but how do you do it if
you don't know what's happening in the
market I'm going to show you how order
flow will help you understand what's
happening in the market so you can limit
your risk and the last thing I'll touch
on is for you to understand that there's
more to trading than just having a
successful trading strategy okay that's
just one part of trading there's you
know trading is like a puzzle right you
got to put the different pieces together
for it to be solved but you know to have
some say
in the markets now again one of the
things I'm not I don't have a slide for
but if you stick around if you watch my
presentation I do have a bribe for you a
reward so to speak is going to show you
how to get a copy of my 150 page book
entitled trading order flow you know
it's a lot of my thoughts and things
I've learned over the years trading
order flow now people that don't know me
I've been a professional trader for you
know close to 20 years you know I spent
eight years JP Morgan vice president of
Futures Trading for years at Cargill I
ran the trading desk before that I was
with Commerce Bank for another three
years
you know Commerce Bank is a big German
bank and before that is with EDF man and
I had started on the CM II floor so you
know when I say professional training
that that's what I mean professional
trading not someone oh you know this is
what I do in my spare time no that's
what I did that's what I did to pay the
rent you know pay for my house put my
kids in school pay for my car everything
that's how I earned my money and that's
what I did for 20 years so now I'm
trying to share that information with
people so they can understand the
markets better because you know honestly
nowadays these markets are just berserk
and everyone is getting all excited
about trading Bitcoin and cryptocurrency
which is you know something that's like
you know take your regular markets and
put them on steroids you know in the
crypto markets you're looking at up and
down 15% there's like a normal trading
day I mean that's just bizarre and you
know most people don't understand the
risks that are involved with trading
because they don't understand trading
you know they just think well you know
bitcoin is going to be keep going up
forever no you know if you're a trader
you understand markets go up markets go
down and it's understanding what's going
on in the markets is how you become
successful so sign up for this
presentation the link is below in the
description or go to order Flo's comm
slash register dot HTML and it will also
take you to the sign up page again you
know it doesn't matter if you use the
link from investor inspiration down
below or you go to my website either one
will take you to the same place so
thanks everyone and I hope to see you
there on Thursday bye bye
you